Yeah, and we can also screen card all the phones to see where they're testing and stuff.
Fuck, that's not a bad idea.
Are you guys just doing it on your laptop?
I don't know, yeah, that was our plan.
I mean, you can just download the Figma app.
Just download the Figma app, as long as you have the flows.
Screen recording's good.
It doesn't really matter too much for usability.
You have to record that.
For the testing, you can see how long it takes for each one.
I suppose you can record on the laptop as well.
Yeah, I'm not using my laptop, I'm using my phone.
Oh, yeah, you can use that.
So, officially we're going to start now.
So, welcome to this testing, I guess.
We're going to be testing our prototype, which is for a Flatmates Expense app.
Really?
Yeah, it is.
So, just go through the app.
I'm going to be giving you some tasks which you have to go through and try and complete them.
Make sure you say what you're thinking and just go through your step, take your time.
But just make sure you can tell me what you're thinking about in each step.
Right, so I'm assuming you filled the consent form earlier, so that's all good.
And we will be recording the voice and also your inputs, I guess, for this test for future use.
But we will be leaving the data after the assignment is done, so that's all that.
So, I'm just going to be setting this up.
It's just going to take a minute.
It's all good, just keep recording.
We're just bashing you.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
Yeah, that's why we are here.
I would go for the seat form.
Yeah, I was confused for a second.
And the screen recording will also record your voice and the things you answer.
It's pretty cool, Figma, because that's how it looks.
Okay, so I'm going to be starting the recording now, and I'm going to hand you the phone.
So, this is the testing we're just going to start, and your first task will be verify the functionality of adding a new recurring expense.
So, you'll be adding a new recurring expense and verifying that it has actually been added.
And when adding the recurring expense, you'll be splitting it among household members.
Okay, so I'm clicking add expense, because that's like the standard Google thing.
I'm just making this up, right?
Read.
Category.
What did you say it was again?
Just any expense.
1,200? I don't think any of ours work in that way either.
There we go, there's our date done.
And repeat. Did you say how often?
It doesn't say how often, but just choose your favorite.
Every week. I'm going to split it with Sam and Alex and me.
My description.
Whatever it says for me.
I'm going to click create.
Sweet.
And then I'm done.
I'm going to go into expenses and look at future expenses.
And then, I can't remember what I even set it to.
Just verify it's been added, I guess.
What was it? 1,200 or something.
I assume it would be there.
Okay, that's fine.
That's the first task which is done, so let's just go back to the homepage.
The next task is to ensure the functionality of paying an existing expense and removing it from the list.
Basically, there's going to be an existing expense which you already paid, but you're going to be paying up the expense to another person.
Just making sure it's already been done.
What would you be doing in this case?
I assume these are my most recent expenses, so I'll go pay up.
Then I'll pay Alex back for his rent.
Okay.
I'll click pay.
What is it? Just the bottom one that works. Pay.
Then I'm paying for power.
Yep.
And then what was the last bit?
Just make sure it's been removed.
It's been removed?
Yep.
Well, I'd just look in there.
Okay, that's nice.
Then go back to the homepage.
Your third task is just view the past expenses and verify the payment history.
How would you be doing that?
Go expenses.
Yep.
Then verify payment history.
Just verifying payment.
Just looking through.
Let's say you want to locate the expense for the garbage from the previous week.
Yep.
So how would you be doing that?
I'd look through. I'd go into the past week section.
Then look and open it.
There we go. That's all our garbage info.
Yeah.
Nice. Okay.
Now let's go back to the homepage again.
Going to the fourth task.
The fourth task is just look at the insights feature for the rent category.
Is this still going to keep on recording while that's calling?
I don't know if it's going to keep on recording or not.
Sorry about that.
The fourth task is just looking at the insights for the rent category
and just making sure you can see a visual representation for the rent category.
Okay, so I'm going to go to insights at the bottom.
And then there's rent. That's the amount.
And then at the top there's what percentage of it it is.
And what if you want to go specifically and view the insights for rent itself?
Can I just click on it?
There we go.
That's our week's rent or our month's rent.
That's nice. Okay.
And task five is just test the customizability.
So test display accessibility features.
So how would you be doing that?
I'm going to click up here where I'm going to find, hopefully, settings or something.
Yeah.
Go in there, then app settings, then display settings.
Then display settings.
I'm going to change it to dark mode if that works.
Okay.
You actually coded that, don't you?
So you can look at other features as well in the display settings.
We've got contact, FAQs, managing categories.
I'm not sure what week start day does.
That's fine.
Okay, so let's go back to the homepage again.
Genuine hope, sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
I believe it was light mode.
Yeah.
Right.
So now your sixth task, which I believe it's the last task, it's test the help and support functionalities.
So imagine you require some help with the app.
You want to look for some help within the app.
So what would you be doing in that case?
I'm going to go to the hamburger bar again.
Yeah.
What do you actually call that?
I think it's a hamburger.
Yeah, it is.
It is called a hamburger.
Okay, I'm going to go help and support.
No, I'm going to go app settings.
Okay.
But we're going to assume that it did just take you there.
So I assume that just wasn't coded in.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Then I'm going to look at the frequently asked questions.
And then here's some of my answers.
I don't know what I'm looking for, but I found it.
That's nice.
Or I'm going to contact support and send them an email.
How would you send them the email?
I'm going to put in my first name, Cassie.
That's me.
My email and my message.
There we go.
Sweet.
Right.
They'll get in contact with me.
So those were all the six tasks.
I hope you remember how to go back to the homepage.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Yeah.
So how was your experience?
Were there any sort of pain points or points you got confused?
I mean, there's a couple of buttons that sort of just don't work.
Can you remember which ones they were?
Like, like there.
Help and support.
Yeah.
That doesn't do anything.
When you're, or some of the other ones.
I've now just forgotten them all.
Oh, it's just a little bit funky how like when you're putting in text it just auto fills
it, but it's more of a like, like prototype type of thing.
Yeah.
It just doesn't have that functionality there.
Which one of the tasks do you think was the most like easiest, easiest to do?
Like intuitive to do?
Probably adding an expense.
Adding expense.
It's just right there.
And which one of them was more difficult to kind of understand and do?
Probably pay up because I could have gone in here.
Like I never even went into the screen.
I just did it on the home screen, but I'm guessing that the functionality is essentially
the same.
You can do it if you want.
Yeah.
I can just click pay and then pay for power.
So it's sort of the exact same, but in a way it's good that there's multiple ways to do
it.
That is one of the heuristics.
That's nice.
And then like, yeah, in this power screen, like only the bottom.
Yeah.
Only the bottom one actually works.
Do you have any sort of like visual details or like anything you didn't quite like?
Regarding like the appearance or the colors used?
The colors are fine.
It's good to have like the, what should we call it?
Like all the display settings and stuff.
Yeah.
Damn.
I'm surprised you coded those.
I only did one of mine.
But yeah, so you can change the colors for like accessibility and all that.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
So overall thoughts?
It's pretty decent.
Right.
Yeah.
Especially for a prototype, like obviously some things would have to be like kind of
polished, but like that's sort of not what you're looking for, is it?
It's just, it does everything you need to.
The only thing that it's obviously missing is, yeah, just like an easy way to add like
flatmates and stuff in, but that's more of a like setup type of thing than a day to day
thing.
Like we're kind of assuming this is already, you've been using it for a while, right?
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Yes.
But you've got the setting there, so it's not like it's hard to find or anything.
Okay.
That makes it nice.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Right.
Thank you for that.
Thank you for giving us your time and to test our prototype.
Thanks.
Thanks for joining us and hope you have a nice day.
Yeah.
Not like you won't be getting big in five minutes time.
Doing the exact same thing.
That's exactly ten minutes.